the only real sports are auto racing
bull fighting and mountain climbing the
rest are just games never heard that one
you never heard that the classic
hemingway you got to use that
we have a combined 60 years of rock
climbing experience at an elite level
the dawn wall was my quest to really
find my physical limits
it's still considered the hardest big
wall free climb in the world
free solar climbing means climbing with
no rope to protect you the fact that he
was the first one to free solo well cap
was such a big deal people didn't think
that it would ever get free solo
the lessons you take from climbing
around success and failure helps put the
rest of life in perspective
climbing is like a fine spice that
brings out the flavor of the rest of us
[Music]
we have spent quite a bit of time
refining our own climbing and we are
happy to share that knowledge with
anybody who's interested in the sport
footwork is generally the most important
part of climbing it all looks
horrendously uncomfortable but you get
used to it the point of using your arms
and rock climbing is to keep you
balanced over your feet so that your
feet can push you up the wall
98 of bouldering is just falling off
falling over and over he was like oh
this is actually a perfect example of
where technique matters because right
now i'm hanging off two holes kind of
strenuous on the fingers but instead i
can lean in push my knee against the
wall look i can suddenly go down hands
we also sprinkle in a little bit of the
psychological aspects of the sport and
how to not look like a gumby
it's a fun term for for a beginner if
you're wearing your climbing shoes in
the parking lot you're gumby
[Music]
climbing is a really incredible way to
connect with nature
all of my craziest experiences all my
hardest experiences
all my best experiences are all
associated with climbing i've made
pretty intentional choices with the way
i lead my life i welcome anybody else to
do the same
that doesn't mean to free solo i mean to
think about their life critically
[Music]
i'm tommy caldwell and i'm alex
and this is my master class we've
totally i'm tommy caldwell and i'm alex
honold and this is masterclass
[Music]
masterclass don't be a gummy
[Music]
so
[Music]